knowing what you know about these ad
networks and the dark arts here what
percentage of clicks
on the internet
writ large
across everything
is
let's say
uh fraudulent
or
bots
if you have to pick a percentage or a
range
what is what is the industry's
take and what does zach's take
i mean
it's a big number
um
it the most of the fraud occurs
traditionally and this kind of actually
open this is this opens a can of worms
most the fraud traditionally occurs
around
unmeasurable areas so think about a
click you know in when you measure by
the click if i drive 100 clicks to your
website you see those 100 clicks come
through that url string those users show
up now they're on your website you can
see what they do you see how many of
them purchase and then you basically say
okay i paid you a thousand dollars for
those hundred clicks and i got ten
thousand dollars in sales my margin is
twenty percent therefore i made two
thousand dollars in marginal dollars
therefore i'm happy to have paid you you
know a thousand dollars um and if they
send you 100 clicks and 100 then they're
fraud and you get no dollars in sales
you're like hey by the way i'm not
paying you for those clicks and so with
a click attribution you can pretty
clearly delineate what is truly um
effective or what's not now when you
move away from clicks that's where fraud
starts to occur because now i can
basically send a bot over to your
website and
you don't know where they came from and
google's like hey we claimed credit for
that purchase but you don't know what
they saw and so like it gets really
smooshy so most of the fraud is
attacking traditional stupid tv
advertisers who go buy
you know video ads online and you see it
all the time right you're on some shady
ass website and like 10 different
pop-ups show up with all these auto play
videos and it's like total spam and like
each of those
each of those advertisers is getting
ripped off and they're doing the same
thing with their bot traffic and they're
driving it at that at that of those
videos at very high levels um
the total percentage of the internet i
don't know i mean i don't have access
it's a big number it's it's billions and
billions of dollars of fraud every year
and what the
um resolution to this is is every system
has some fraud the credit card network
has some fraud and can the advertisers
the publishers and the ad networks agree
at the end of the day that the fraud is
manageable
and as you're saying if you sent me 100
clicks and it netted me 2 000 in profits
at the end of the day
if 10 or 20
were fraudulent clicks i'm blending that
into my cost per click i'm blending that
into my ad spend just like a restaurant
or a tire shop
my or a catalog person might be like
yeah we're gonna have two or three
percent or credit card companies say
yeah that's gonna be two percent one
percent fraud and if you want to you can
pay a higher percentage
for your credit card fees to not get
signatures not look at the card if you
look at the card you know you
uh compare less like i think that's why
when you get coffee
they never ask you for your credit card
or your id and when you buy a flat
screen tv they ask you to see the actual
credit card i guess exactly yeah yeah
yeah um yeah it's it you know what
happened what's the unfortunate thing is
that it's the unsophisticated
advertisers who get ripped off here so
if you're
you know an old-school brand and you
hire a stupid agency they're going to
waste your money you're going to get
taken to the cleaners if you're like a
small advertiser and you're not
sophisticated and you don't have good
technology you get taken advantage of so
it's not that the fraud is evenly
distributed like sophisticated
advertisers know how to measure and
manage and deal with it and they can
they can identify the vendors who are
who are driving out of fraud and they
get rid of them rapidly um the
unsophisticated folks they get taken to
town and it's most of it's a lot of
these old school big brands you just see
like you know the
just big old dumb stupid brands and they
just
lose money so interesting that they're
not building up their internal
capability because
you know you hire young folks who are
super tech savvy who are coming into the
space you know as digital natives
and you just say listen figure out how
these networks work run a bunch of tests
you could build this muscle internally
it's strange that they don't given how
important these channels are to them
i mean it's er
the problem is that historically you've
got these cmos who are old-school tv
guys and they've been doing tv their
whole life and that's how they think
about the world and digital is they've
never really figured it out and but
they've got to move money into digital
because they they have to look like they
know what they're doing and so they go
to their agency and they're like good
spend x percent on digital because they
can't go to the board and be like well i
can't spend a digital because i can't
figure it out and so and then these
agencies i mean
they're a lot of them are good at tv and
not very good at much else and so they
just take the money and they just dump
it they're like they go to their vendors
and they're like yeah just go spend it
and the money just gets spent doing dumb
stuff over and over and over again
because it's the budget so big
yeah both of those paradigms seem to be
ending the paradigm of that cmo is
coming to an end they'll retire at some
point uh and then
uh
we have a um
a very interesting thing happen i don't
know if you're experiencing this but i
am inoculating myself to advertising
you know hulu has a no ad product i have
youtube with pro with no ads netflix and
disney and hbo max do not have ads i
would say that's the majority of my
media consumption right there and the
idea of me watching ads when i pay for
nba league pass i paid an extra 40 bucks
a year i think to not have ads but show
the local cameras in the arena and my
god it was the best decision i've ever
made my kids do not watch advertising
yeah it just doesn't happen in our
household and what impact will that have
over time and do you think that that's
going to be a trend where consumers
just pay that incremental dollar to get
advertising
out of their video streams
specifically jason the one thing you
seem to forget is you're rich and not
everyone else is rich so
most consumers still pay nothing and
they still get advertised too but the
best way to think about it is you have a
continuum so like in the continuum you
have on one end you can think about it
like tv commercials so when you watch a
tv show it's 30 minutes but it's
how many minutes of
sight sound in motion it's like like
over 12 i think it's 12 right now yeah i
think in an hour it would be over 12
yeah i think it's usually when i watch a
30 minute sitcom
it's usually 21 to 24 minutes and that
means that would imply six to nine
minutes of ads so double that for an
hour and that's a full interruption
in motion where you literally are
sitting there watching like commercials
attempting to brainwash but you and i
can remember tv as we saw when we were
kids like i can remember hulk hogan's tv
ads i can remember like the the the um
uh
my little pony
phone um
like or um i mean like so so we were
effectively brainwashed when we were
kids because back then we watched
television portals and then on the other
end of the continuum you can think about
like a data-driven ad that really knows
you so it knows what you buy it knows
where you live it knows like everything
about you and that data can be used to
deliver really valuable useful stuff to
you it can be like hey here's the thing
that we know you want and that you will
buy and you're like oh i want that can
you buy and those become so
good that you don't even notice them as
ads anymore because they they enter into
your life in a way that's useful and
provides value and so on that continuum
tv commercials no data and so they have
to interrupt you know a third of your
life and just brainwash you and on the
other end it's like becomes almost like
it doesn't interrupt you at all because
it's so valuable to you um
and uh yeah it could be interesting to
see how it plays out
micro acquire is a startup acquisition
marketplace that cuts out the middlemen
basically that means they help startups
get acquired efficiently if you've ever
had to buy a company or you tried to
sell your company there's all these
people in the middle they're not looking
out for you micro requires looking out
for you to date microacquire has helped
hundreds of startups get acquired and
has facilitated hundreds of millions of
dollars in closed deal volume
over a hundred thousand buyers on the
platform right now it's amazing i signed
up for it i paid for it now they're an
advertiser it's crazy thousands of
startups are currently listed for sale
on the site and they've had hundreds of
successful acquisitions so far because
they vet all of the deals they're
putting up there and they vet all the
buyers founders get free and instant
access to these hundred thousand trusted
buyers while staying totally anonymous
this is not like an open marketplace if
you're a founder looking to sell
microacquire is free private and
involves no middle men on the other side
of the marketplace buyers simply pay 290
a year for access to the platform like i
did because i might buy some stuff for
inside.com microacquire help startups
find buyers simple as that they'll help
you start conversations that can lead to
an acquisition in just 30 days for free
at try.microacquire.com
twist
try.microacquire.com twist go ahead
founders and check it out and if you're
an acquirer or you're looking to beef up
your startups footprint you really
should just pay the 290 in peruse and
see what you could buy there it's a
really cool service